as she was making some dreams come true
for his fans and more specifically for
insecure star Issa Ray who was treated
to an extra special performance yeah
he's attended the singer's Las Vegas
residency show over the weekend where
Usher decided to personally serenade her
with his song superstars
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
do you mind if I just sing a couple
songs to you
can I just like serenade you a little
bit
come on we about to just flip the whole
show up come here
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
hello that is that is awesome how fun is
that who would you want to be serenaded
by
um oh my goodness that is a great
question who would I want to be sick no
what's his name oh what's Joey McIntyre
yeah Joey McIntyre New Kids on the Block
could potentially be but also like Bruno
Mars Bruno Mars what about you yeah
we'll go with Bruno Mars too right yeah
that'd be amazing oh but that's Justin
Bieber but like in a sister way like
yeah right yeah yeah any yeah Justin
Bieber that's just iconic that's just a
great moment for her to she's gonna
remember forever
do you want